people have these different handicaps
they place on themselves where they are
cognizant of all these different flaws
they have and then they think that that
makes them not good enough for the girls
and then that causes the rejection and
that like reinforces the belief and then
it just continues in a cycle right and
people are you know not many people are
cold approaching anyways like even even
in your Generation stuff like that no
but it's gotten even less common yeah
much less and with covid and stuff like
this you know not many people are going
out and I I think that even once like
night venues and stuff reopened not as
many people go out anymore and a lot of
clients I work with their ego is like
very tied to approaching a female in
public so if that girl rejects them they
feel horrible about themselves and it's
it's tough for them to go back in and
try again and then if that rejection
happens again and it keeps it's like
it's like a negative momentum and then
they they just usually give up so my job
is to to show them like look you have
you can totally do this and show them
real tangible results and